la situación sanitaria de brasil vuelve
a ser crítica por segunda jornada
consecutiva se batió el récord en el
número de fallecidos al llegar a los
1910 en 24 horas datos que llevan al
sistema sanitario al borde del colapso y
que han obligado a sao paulo a aplicar
restricciones del 8 al 19 de marzo sólo
operará el comercio esencial en el motor
económico de brasil algo que muchos
lamentan
esta es la triste realidad de un país
dirigido por un negacionista a un país
que no tiene un ministerio de salud de
ministerios y un país que un país que no
tiene coordinación de salud pública que
está en la peor crisis sanitaria en la
peor crisis sanitaria de los últimos 100
años los últimos 6 jones gran parte de
las culpas caen sobre el presidente ya
ir bolsonaro y su política ya que apenas
se han aplicado medidas de contención a
la variante amazónica del virus que se
ha demostrado que es más contagiosa que
el patógeno original sin embargo hay
brasileños que defienden que a pesar de
la situación
la economía debe de seguir abierta para
evitar que la gente deje de trabajar
preocupado la gente está preocupada pero
tenemos muchas necesidades físicas y
psicológicas necesitamos trabajar
tenemos que salir a la calle y hacer
nuestro dinero y ganarnos el pan aunque
brasil ha inoculado ya una dosis al 4,16
por ciento de su población muchos
sostienen que el proceso está yendo
demasiado lento para inmunizar a más de
200 millones de personas y que puede
verse afectado si el virus sigue
extendiéndose a la velocidad actual